des centaines de pas vers la
réconciliation pour le dialogue entre
les communautés en marchant on s'ouvre
le coeur on jase plus juste avec ma tête
mon genre avec nono notre coeur et nos
tripes c'est lui le docteur cette année
volant qui organise ces marche partout à
travers le québec
chirurgien rêve d'une société plus
équitable avec les premières nations et
surtout pour les prochaines générations
si on ne développe pas le plein
potentiel cesse d'augmenter leur bâti
qu'on a convié aujourd'hui au niveau de
la santé au niveau de la justice au
niveau d'éducation un nouveau décrochage
collège tht terreur damballa il donne un
espoir aux jeunes autochtones la moitié
des 1 million 700 mille autochtones au
pays sont âgés de moins de 20 ans plus
de 60 % d'entre eux abandonnent l'école
avant la troisième année du secondaire
adam vincent étudie pour devenir médecin
il veut marcher dans les pas du docteur
volant d'aider les premières nations à
être soignés dans leur santé en
travaillant comme aide ça mais aussi en
mettant un message c'est possible pour
les condamnations d'atteindre le rêve de
prendre des positions importantes
je suis vraiment fier je te dirai je
contacter sabrina godbout est une jeune
huronne wendat lorsqu'elle a quitté sa
communauté pour la grande ville elle
s'est aussi posé des questions sur sa
culture
je pense que tout le monde passe par le
que peu importe d'où est-ce que tu
arrives puis c'est quand même un défi
d'essayer de 10 rebonds mais continue à
parler ma langue continue à pratiquer ta
culture quand tic tout le monde
d'habitude et dans sa communauté en
marche âge quand même
[Musique]
c'est pas juste
oui car on apprenait sur les attaques
tentées constitue en apprenant avec on a
des bijoux on a des petits rock vocale
est taillé pour donner forme à les plus
beaux les plus beaux diamants n'a plus
ni moins ici pierre alexandre bolduc
radio canada québec